asking men what they value and the
problem is when you start asking men
shout out rest in peace Kevin Samuels
okay he he highlighted this and he
highlighted that when men speak and when
men think and when men feel and when men
Express their opinions right
women that are single mothers of like
two three four or however many children
fat chicks too right you have to
understand how men speak and how men
feel and it offends you
that's not our problem can I ask you but
men are allowed to have their standards
okay
wait wait Amanda with a man where the
woman has standards men are not offended
if you say you don't want shoot guys all
right cool you don't want to shoot guys
but the man says I don't want a baby
mother oh my God
you get offended it's like it's crazy
you're not allowed to have standards too
I'm not gonna lie I don't want a baby
that evil he a man could actually have
all the things that he did everything
and if he has kids I'm like no Dada
straight away respect a man that
actually says raw listen I don't want
this this is not what I want but you as
a woman have to understand that that's
not his standard no but I tell you
something so so would you you will break
all of your rules for the right guy
if you ask kids [ __ ] no no no
I guarantee you when you will break all
of your rules I have been in a situation
I'm your virgin let me just ask you a
question are you a virgin no yeah right
so uh
that guy has a baby all right so I'm not
gonna
I'm not gonna do a relationship but then
at the same time you're not even a
virgin no no no no no can I say why can
I say why I would not give a guy the
chance can I say why I would not give a
guy that has kids because me as a person
I know myself and I can't give those
kids the love that they require that's
the reason why I can't I can't be around
someone else's child then after that I
know he's had another woman and I
already know as a man you know you're
gonna go and do your little ting
tingling with your baby mom let's be
real now no I believe it
okay
guys
I I agree with you like a single thought
like again it wouldn't be my first
choice it wouldn't because I just think
there's baggage that comes with that
exactly but you get it but like why why
when Sarah was saying the same thing you
guys were like but that doesn't make her
less valuable no because the way he said
that just sounded Madness
you know you just got to you've got
we don't give a [ __ ] about your feelings
we're talking about the facts the fact
is I understand as a man that being a
father of another child I understand
that a lot of women may say I'm a curb
that guy I'm not taking that guy because
he's got a child I understand that and
I'm cool with that and that's a fact my
feelings don't come into that situation
the problem is is that when you say the
same thing to women oh but I feel like
we don't give a [ __ ] about your feelings
because you know why it's the same thing
I think the difference is why all the
girls were saying and it goes back to
what he said your guy you two are saying
if a God has a child she's a five but it
completely depends on the child the
relationship with the child like I might
meet a guy his baby mum's tapped always
involved that's a that's a fall
immediate side chick though no no no no
beginning okay so so you're so you're
saying it depends based on the girl
that's what you're saying and it depends
on how the person let's if you have
someone that doesn't let you paint their
child at all how can that ever work okay
so you're looking at it from a woman's
point of view yes because for us it
depends based on because my mum a guy
parent me your mom
I don't know I don't know your personal
situation I'm not going to speak on like
your life I don't know it but I'm saying
I'm saying in general it's not men's
first choice
and it really doesn't matter the
situation I I don't know who your
stepdad is but typically it's lower
status men that don't have a ton of
options because if you look at the men
with the money and the power and that
have the most options they tend to pick
young single childless women
again
no I totally agree with you I've been
brought with boys like men my uncle my
dad so I fully understand that I feel
like it doesn't matter what color
caliber man is that whether he's got
money or poor or whatever they still do
go for the same thing with it's pure
innocent they still go for the same
thing because at the end of the day as I
said before earlier what I was trying to
touch on is that in our nature men want
to be a provider they want to so
therefore they want to their legacy to
go on and therefore right to their kids
exactly and therefore as women we are
like we are printers we we're gonna
imprint this no we are we're human
printers we're gonna print that man so
therefore he's going to look at us and
one
there's some single mothers that are
like better than others yes so so not
not all of them you know one girl might
get minus five or let's say seven points
because her baby daddy was you know in
jail yeah but and one might and one
might get it but the point
but you're missing the point the point
is regardless if you have a child you
get points unattracted I know that's why
that's what I was saying I know I know
you got a child yeah yes Ralph how old
is your child he's three he's three how
old are you I'm 21. okay so hang on this
is this is great so
um
no no but you're a 21 year old yeah with
a three-year-old yeah which means you
have your child at 18. yes okay Oscar
how hang on no no it's not even that I'm
saying do you think so the type of man
that you're looking for the type of man
that you may be looking for yeah right
you have to understand that that man he
because you're 21. yeah you may be
looking for a 27 year old maybe at this
point in time right I will be looking at
somebody else yeah like you might be
looking for a guy who's like 27.'s
mature yeah a bit more older than you
yeah if a guy's 27
yeah that means he's in his
quote-unquote prime of life okay he's
building that he's building himself up
to be a man yeah do you think a man
who's building himself up to be a man
he's looking to take on another man's
shirt
it all comes down to different like
everyone's different and everyone's
Minds different everyone's mindset
generally do you think generally you
think a single 27 year old generally no
he probably is looking for a single one
without any trouble
exactly but no but no at the same time
right if if I meet a girl yeah and she's
21 23 whatever yeah and she's a single
mom but she was married
and she had a baby in a marriage
I would look at her that's different
it's different now
it's different right let me make a point
bro let me make a point
if she was married and she has a baby in
the in that marriage and then
at some time the marriage collapse right
I would I would I wouldn't I wouldn't
look at her the same as as this as this
road lady that's just
a [ __ ] guys
different right this is the this is the
mindset of matters of men this is an 18
year old unmarried woman I was married
you were married yeah okay so you see
crazy
so you were a married woman of 18 that
had a child I didn't even know that
brother right okay
so what I'm trying to say do you
understand how men's Minds differ
because if you were an unmarried woman
but maybe because if you want unmarried
woman at 18 that had a child that wasn't
committed to a relationship yeah you
were just some random chick
men would be like
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis is on this platform if you
want to help please consider sending a
super thanks below every donation helps
and it helps make what we do possible